hey this is going to be very interesting
the first-ever private moon tourist is
scheduled to go to the moon or at least
to fly around it the tourist is going to
be Japanese billionaire yuusaku Misawa
the company taking him there is SpaceX
and it's expected to happen in the year
2023
misawa's plan is to take six to eight
artists from around the world on what's
going to be a week-long round-trip they
will go to the moon maybe do a lap or
two around the moon and then come back
to earth I actually think it would be
better to take mostly flat earthers and
conspiracy theorists who believe we
never landed on the moon maybe there
would still be some visible evidence of
the fact that we went to the moon rather
than artists might be more useful SpaceX
is CEO Elon Musk is of course the guy
who is simultaneously in charge of the
more and more beleaguered Tesla which
we've been talking about as I spoke
about on the bonus show late last week
earlier this week late last week it was
I have gotten rid of half of my shares
of Tesla won't go into that in detail
here but talked about that on on the
bonus show and the plan according to
musk is to go back to the moon for the
first time in 50 years using a bfr
that's a big Falcon rocket that's what's
been developed by SpaceX it's 35 stories
tall it can take off and land like
SpaceX the SpaceX Falcon 9 rocket but
instead of being set up to carry just
satellites it can carry dozens of people
how much did my zawa pay for this
privilege Elon Musk isn't saying other
than to say it's quote very significant
which sounds about right exciting time
to be alive this could either be the
plot of a mediocre sci-fi book a
billionaire and eight of the world's
most eccentric artists are going to be
locked up in tight confines for a
week-long trip or it actually could be
something absolutely fascinating for the
future of space travel
and not not to burst bubbles people seem
a little bit confused about this I
wanted to say this again because I know
that in the comments people are going to
misunderstand they are not landing on
the moon they're going to the moon
presumably entering orbit around the
moon one or two laps around unclear and
then they are coming back to earth so
it's more of a fly by but still
extraordinarily interesting and from a
science angle I've been saying for a
while that we should go back to the moon
both in terms of what is being done here
but actually landing on the moon it's
been so long since we did that space
travel technology has advanced so much
we are talking about going to Mars and
two points that are even further why not
use the relatively close by moon as a
training ground for the types of
technology that we would want to use to
go elsewhere there's the counterpoint to
that is often the amount that it costs
to do that is so huge that were better
off just putting that money into
developing better technology to go
directly to Mars or directly somewhere
else I I disagree I think that the
potential benefit of going back to the
moon with 50 year newer technology than
what we had during the late 60s could be
hugely beneficial and my question to you
today is do you care about this stuff I
know that there are some people in our
audience who are very interested in
what's going on with space travel NASA
SpaceX but every 10 Mars every time I
talk about it particularly Mars I will
get some angry voicemails from some of
the normal trolls but also from other
people who don't often get in touch who
say David this is not a good use of
money this is not interesting it is
dangerous to constantly talk about going
elsewhere and humanity going elsewhere
because it excuses continuing to destroy
the planet and makes excuses for not
fixing the climate change issues that we
are dealing with so I don't want you
talking about space travel and space
exploration that is not my point of view
but I do want to hear from you let me
know